let me ask your opinion since you
mentioned him andrew tate you're both
women successful women you're both
creators so andrew t is an example of
somebody
that has become exceptionally successful
at
galvanizing public attention
but he's also
from many perspective a misogynist so
let me ask a personal question
do you think i should talk to him on
this podcast
how would you feel as a fan
as somebody i'm talking to the great
alex and andrea bortes and the next
episode is with andrew tay
i think it's a double-edged sword and
most of these things are not as black
and white as they seem
um you know because on one hand i don't
agree with his beliefs and i think he's
said a lot of things that are very
hurtful and that influence
people's opinions
at the same time talking to someone
through that and trying to get to the
root of it and how much of it he used
just as a social media tactic
to maybe change the opinion of people
who have been so influenced by him
towards
something that is maybe more
understanding towards women or things
like that
could
do some good but at the same time
platforming someone like that and giving
them more attention also signals to
other people who have a platform that
it's okay so it's kind of weighing the
pluses and the minuses it's a very tough
decision because it's not clear
and uh the thing about the internet when
you make the wrong decision you're going
to pay for it right
that's the thing like personally
and it is it is funny like i think the
whole way rose to fame is just a growth
hack and i've seen other people do it
where like you just say kind of
i don't i honestly i don't really listen
to his content because i just find it so
dumb but i think he knows that by saying
the dumbest most controversial things
that's like a quick rise to fame and i
think surface level like
he can really hold it up but that's why
i would honestly enjoy tuning into a
conversation where you're really
breaking down to the core of those
beliefs and i think like the young kids
who look up to him and when you actually
hear someone challenging it could
actually be helpful for people but at
the same time
it's a lot of bad publicity people see
your podcast they say wow like they
don't if they don't know you and they
don't know why you're interviewing him
and they don't listen they'll see that
and 100
think it's for the other reason
but i'm also afraid of a society where
you can't have discourse with people you
don't dis with people you disagree with
and even though i don't like andrew tate
i think the fact that he got banned from
all the platforms is kind of scary
because it sets a precedent and you
always have to ask yourself would this
be ethical if i was on the other side
and even things with a president like
trump even if let's say you're somebody
who was on the left if that would have
happened to a leftist president how
would you feel would you think that's
morally ethical so
that is something that i think is
important we try to find ways to have
conversations and
reach some mutual understanding and try
instead of just amplifying the worst
about every human being
well so one of the major reasons us i'm
struggling with is because i really
enjoy
talking to brilliant women i think
it's also a lot of women reached out to
me saying like
it is what it is but they're inspired
when the female guest is on yeah and to
me if i talk to somebody like andrew tay
even if i have a really hard hitting
i think it could be a very good
conversation
that
lessens the likelihood that
a brilliant powerful female will go on
the show
because they will never they'll never
watch it but we the thing we're doing in
this society is we put labels on each
other well
lex is the person that platforms
misogynist yep
i did a thing
where um
joe rogan got in in trouble over an
n-word uh controversy earlier in the
year and joe's a good friend of mine and
i said that i stand with joe that he's
not a racist or something like that
and within certain communities i'm now
somebody who's an apologist for racists
right or a racist myself uh that kind of
thing and we put labels without ever
listening to the content without ever
uh sort of
actually just even the very simple step
or seems to be difficult of like
taking on the best possible
interpretation of what a person said and
giving him the benefit of the doubt and
having empathy for another person so you
have to play in this field where people
assign labels to each other
and uh
it's difficult but ultimately i believe
i hope that
good conversations
is a way
to like a greater understanding for
people to um
grow together as a society and improve
and learn the lessons the mistakes of
the past but you also have to play this
game where people just like putting
labels on each other and canceling each
other over those or that guy said one
thing nice about donald trump he must be
a far-right
nazi
or or the opposite that this person
um
said something nice about the vaccine he
must be a far left
um whatever because
uh apologists
for whatever for fauci
um or most of us i think are ultimately
in the middle it's it's a weird it's a
weird thing but i think uh and it's also
painful on a personal level like people
people have written to me
about things like single words
half sentences that i've said about
either putin or zelensky
where they have hate towards me because
of what i said
either both directions i've now
accumulated very passionate people
that
some call me a putin apologist some call
me a zelonsky apologist and it hurts to
given how much i have family there how
much i've seen of suffering there and to
carry that burden over time and not let
it destroy you is tough so like do you
want to take on another thing like that
when you have conversations right or can
i just talk to awesome people like
youtube
where it's not
controversial it's or you're interesting
you're fascinating you're inspiring
you're like
fun you know
not
all those difficult things that come
with more difficult conversations right
but somebody has to be
making those difficult decisions and
challenging the notions that
we should cancel someone just for
slightly disagreeing with us and it's
very hard to take that on personally and
i think that's a huge part of it when
you know it's something you're doing for
the right reasons and you're getting a
lot of people coming and misinterpreting
it it's very painful
but i think you have to ask yourself
long term
if when you made that decision you
ultimately thought it would be better or
worse for your listeners to know that
conversation and then if you can sleep
with it at night take the risk yeah when
actually when i talk to people that uh
especially like astrophysicists and you
realize how tiny we are right how
incredible like how huge the universe is
like you don't it doesn't matter you can
do anything you could like
um you can walk around naked talk [ __ ]
to people do whatever the hell
and uh actually in modern social media
people will just like forget it's like
it's ultimately liberating just try to
do
at least from my perspective the best
possible thing for the world you can
take big risks
it doesn't matter and that's the other
thing with being canceled nowadays
because everyone's attention is much
more short-sighted you can get cancelled
and then it'll blow over in three days
and you actually see things like this on
twitch very often where people just have
outbursts of outrage and they come into
your chat and they're all spamming and
saying mean things and then three days
after and of course they're not actually
ever serious things they're usually like
things clipped of any streamers and like
their worst moments but then people
forget about it pretty soon after
so you're able to accept that
like when somebody's being shitty to you
for a day ah yeah i mean i still get
sometimes emotional about it especially
when i'm like oh wow like these things
are being said are not true or like this
is clearly taken out of context but i've
just accepted that it's part of the job
and if i am trying my best and i am
trying things with as good intentions as
possible then i just try to learn every
time that happens and be like okay what
could i do better what is just part of
the job
you